la cour de cassation vient de trancher
marie à pirès ne pourra pas se faire est
implanté six embryons congelés la
justice lui en a refusé le droit mais a
par ailleurs autorisé leurs dons à un
autre couple éventuelle révolte et j'ai
pas de mots pour définir ce que j'aurai
sa vie je détruis emma parties à achever
leur coopérer peut-être un point final à
un long combat mené par maria pires
depuis dix ans avec son mari alors
vivante madame pires fait plusieurs
tentatives pour avoir un enfant
la dernière en 1990 aboutira à lifou ski
c'est alors que son mari décède et l
hôpital de toulouse refuse une nouvelle
implantation ce que le tribunal de
grande instance confirmera homme sait
qu'on a des embryons congelés dans ce
bastion de revenir sur le personnes
relativement âgées qui est stérile
alors est-ce que l'augmentation de
l'embryon dans ces conditions est
souhaitable les hôpitaux le communiqué
estime que non à l'époque en l'absence
de loi en la matière maria pires se
battra devant toutes les juridictions
mais la cour de cassation se référant à
une loi récente il ya opposé un dernier
le législateur a choisi de bien déclaré
que la procréation médicalement assistée
devait être réservée dans toutes ses
phases à des couples vivant et
consentants au moment de l'application
des techniques car depuis juillet 1994
la france s'est dotée d'un cadre
juridique concernant la bioéthique
une loi jugée douloureuse par maria
pires mais qui était très attendue par
bon nombre de praticiens qui évolue et
avant elle dans le plus pur flou
juridique